[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> So I'm off to Davos.
What do I want from world leaders at Davos?
Well, I think first of all getting this issue
on people's agendas is so
important.
We need to break the taboo.
We need to move FGM out of the silent margins
where it's been and
really into the mainstream.
I want everyone who is working on women empowerment
and girls education
to ensure that FGM is on their agenda.
I want people to realize the enormity of what's
happening to 3 million
girls a year.
I want people to believe that this is our
problem.
It's not just happening elsewhere.
It's happening within our communities.
And we are a global community.
Things like this shouldn't be, oh, it's Africa,
oh, it's Indonesia, oh,
it's Islam.
It's not.
It's up to all of us to play a part in this.
I want to see if we can coalesce and get more
funding and more
resources to this issue.
Yes, times are tough and there are humanitarian
disasters, everything
in the globe that's happening.
And yet, still, when I go to sleep every night
I can still hear that
little girl and what's she's saying is why
won't people help me?
I want to make sure that we can all wake up
and say that we've done
what we can.
And no one more than global leaders who are
taking us through, who are
steering our planet into the next decade.
I want them to be thinking we can do something
about this.
This shouldn't happen on our watch.
Let's wake up and let's end FGM now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]